[موسيقى]
يقول ديزموند توتو كبير اساقفه جنوب
افريقيا الاسبق اذا كنت محايدا في حالات
الظلم فقد اخترت ان تكون بجانب الظالم ان
اسقطنا هذا الاختبار على الموقف من محرقه
غزه نجد ان معظم شعوب العالم ليست محايده
بحسب التقارير بل هي منحازه للفطره
السليمه التي تناصر المظلوم لكن التقارير
ذاتها ستحدث عن دعم معظم الحكومات لا سما
في الغرب او تفهمها او صمتها على الاقل عن
الهولوكوست الاسرائيلي في غزه والمفارقه
ان هذه الحكومات يقولون انها منتخبه من من
شعوبها المؤيده للمظلومين فهان الاوان
لدفن الديمقراطيه الغربيه في تراب غزه
بفلسطين الى
العناوين جنوب افريقيا تسوق اسرائيل الى
لهاي ومن فم نتنياهو
تدينه هل تنام اوراق هولوكوست غزه في
ادراج العدل
الدوليه كاتب متطرف اسرائيل ستحتل مكه
والمدينه وجبل سيناء
ولبنان وزير اسرائيلي سابق حكومتنا تحضر
لظهور ياجوج وماجوج والحرب
الكبرى غضب شعبي يمني بعد الضربات
الامريكيه لمواقع جماعه انصار
الله تل ابيب تدعي ان مفتاح معبر رفح بيد
مصر والقاهره تنفي قنصل مصري يفاخر
بعلاقاته مع اسرائيليات تحت كاميرات
الموساد دخلت دعوه جنوب افريقيا ضد
اسرائيل بتهمه الاباده الجماعيه مرحله
الانتظار المقدره بنحو ثلاثه اسابيع
ليتوصل قضاه المحكمه ال 15 الى اتفاق
واصدار القرار النهائي بعدما اختتمت جلسات
استماع اسرائيل هاجمت جنوب افريقيا وعدتها
الذراع القانونيه لحماس وان دعواها منحازه
وغير قانونيه مرحبا لقد وحدت دماء
الفلسطينيين شعوب الامه واحرار العالم على
نصره المظلومين في غزه الذين يستشهدون
ويجرحون ويشردون ويجوعون بقرار عابر
للمحيطات مانع لوقف النار وبتنفيذ وحشي
اسرائيلي يبرع في حرق المدنيين العزل من
الجو والبحر كلما اخفق جنود الاحتلال في
البر امام رجال المقاومه الفلسطينيه مجازر
الاباده الجماعيه الاسرائيليه ضد
الفلسطينيين حملتها دوله جنوب افريقيا الى
محكمه العدل الدوليه في لاهاي وانتصرت
لفلسطين نيابه عن احرار العالم يعني انت
خصك بهيج ما لك علاقه اسرائيل سيقت الى
المحكمه بانف انفه انف بينوكيو الكذاب
فتخطط حججها مطالعات عبد الله بن ابي ابن
سلول قدمت الى لهاي والدماء الحمراء تقطر
من راسها الى كعبها لتحاد في بياض قلبها
ويديها فماذا كانت لتقول لو لم تكن
مجازرها موجوده بالاف الصور والفيديوهات
وكل لحظه على كل هاتف وشاشه وفي كل بيت في
العالم امام اتهام جنوب افريقيا لها
بارتكاب جريمه اباده جماعيه تتمسك اسرائيل
بالقول ان حماس هي من تسعى
لابادولا الجماعيه وهو النيه في تدمير شعب
كليا او جزئيا غير موجود على
الاطلاق
تريد من خلالها جنوب افريقيا اولا على
المدى القصير تحقيق هدف استصدار قرار او
تدابير عاجله بايقاف الحرب وفسح المجال
للمساعدات الانسانيه بشكل اوسع المدى
الابعد هو جر اسرائيل الى معركه اخلاقيه
وسياسيه كبيره من خلال جوهر القضيه علما
ان جنوب افريقيا لها تاريخ تقليديا تقف
مواقف منتقده لاسرائيل جنوب افريقيا ادانت
اسرائيل من فم رئيس وزرائها في الفيديو
القصير الشهير لنتنياهو وهو يحث جنوده على
ارتكاب الاباده الجماعيه بحق
الفلسطينيين مسقطا كتابهم المقدس ومستعدا
ذكر عماليق لتشريع
الاباده 28 october
2023 preparing for the invasion of gaza
urged the soldiers to remember what
amalek has done to
you this refers to the biblical command
by god to saul for the retaliatory
destruction of an entire group of people
known as the amalekites
put to death men and
women children and infants cattle and
sheep cels and
donkeys the gen invocation to amek was
anything
id it was repe mr n in a letter to the
israel armed forces 3 november
2023 let
prime الخوف في نهايه المحكم من ان تنا
ملفاتها في ادج ال
كما نام هذا القاضي اثناء الجلسه مستبقا
الاحداث منذ 15 اسبوعا وساحه ه بيما في
مدينه تل ابيب تشهد تظاهرات تطالب باقاله
الحكومه بشكل فوري وبخروج
لانتخابات وعشيه اليوم المئ للحرب على
قطاع غزه وبقاء اكثر من 130 اسيرا
اسرائيليا في الاسر تظاهر الاف
الاسرائيليين في ساحتها بيما يجددون
مطلبهم وقد خرج العشرات منهم لاغلاق شارع
ايالون جنوبا لاهاي ولا لاهاي ستوقف
نتنياهو يؤكد ويكاد ان يدعو العالم الى
تذوق عصير اوراق المحكمه بعد نقعها وشرب
مائها غير عابئ باسرا وبمظهر تل ابيب ولا
بمجتمعه الذي تحول جزئيا الى مصحه عقليه
سنواصل الحرب حتى النهايه حتى النصر
الكامل لن يوقفنا احد لا لهاي ولا محور
الشر ولا اي شخص اخر المشتركات بين تاريخي
جنوب افريقيا وفلسطين كثيره اولها انهما
احتلت في نفس العام من القرن الماضي
1948 فلماذا ياتي اوروبيون الى الدوله
الغنيه بالذهب والالماس طلبا للرزق
فيطلبون معه بعد حين السلطه وباب شع
مظاهرها تخيلوا اصدقائي ان تاتي اقليه
لتعيش وتعمل في بلدك فتجد نفسك فجاه تحت
سكاكينها حكايه تعرفون مثيلات لها في
فلسطين وغير فلسطين حكمت القليه البيضاء
في جنوب افريقيا من عام
1948 لمده اربعه عقود وانشات نظاما للفصل
العنصري يهدف الى الهيمنه الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه لهذه الاقليه ذات الاصول
الاوروبيه عرف هذا النظام باسم ابارتيد
يعود الوجود الاوروبي في جنوب افريقيا الى
القرن الساب عشر حين سافرت الى هناك
مجموعات من البريطانيين والهولنديين للعمل
وعلى مدى القرون الثلاثه التاليه قام
هؤلاء الاوروبيون بتوسيع نفوذهم للحصول
على الموارد الطبيعيه الموجوده مثل الذهب
والماس الادانات الدوليه للنظام العنصري
الابيض كان جادا وقد ادركت الاقليه
الحاكمه في جنوب افريقيا ان ساعه رحيلها
عن الحكم قد ازفت مع دخول البلاد في ازمات
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه وامنيه يصعب حلها فالغ
الكثير من قوانين الاستعباد واطلقت من
المعتقل مفجره الثوره نيلسون منديلا الذي
سجن بتهمه التخابر مع دول افريقيه فبعد
سنوات من الادانه والعقوبات الدوليه انتهت
ايام الفصل العنصري في البلاد مع تراس
فريدريك ويليام كليرك الذي كان اخر رئيس
ابيض لجنوب افريقيا وقام باطلاق سراح
نيلسون مانديلا من السجن الذي كان سياسيا
مناهضا للفصل العنصري واصبح بعد تحريره
اول رئيس ذي بشره سمراء في جنوب افريقيا
نيلسون منديلا بطل السلام نعم لكنه حمل
البندقيه ايضا واطلق تنظيم رمح الامه وهو
المقاومه المسلحه للتحرر من الاحتلال
والاستعباد وعليه احمد ياسين خليل الوزير
فتحي الشقاقي وابو علي مصطفى وغيرهم كانوا
يستحقون بجدار نوبل للسلام بدل وضعهم على
قوائم الارهاب والاغتيال المجزره التي
وقعت في شار عام
1961 والتي قتل فيها اكثر من 60 متظاهرا
كانت نقطه التحول الرئيسيه التي دفعت
المؤتمر الوطني الافريقي لتغيير
استراتيجيته وقامت الدوله بحظر الحزب
فاصبحت المقاومه السلميه شيئا من الماضي
الكثير من الناس يشعرون الا فائده من
الاستمرار في الحديث عن السلام ونبذ العنف
ضد حكومه لا ترد الا بهجمات وحشيه على
اناس عز
في اعقاب ذلك قام مدال بانشاء جناح عسكري
للحزب عرف باسم اوم كونتو وي سيزوي او رمح
الامه وكانت اهدافه تخريب امدادات الطاقه
في البلاد وتدمير المباني الحكوميه على
مدار العش عاما التاليه قام الجناح
العسكري بسلسله من التفجيرات وصنف الجناح
كمنظمه ارهابيه من حكومه جنوب افريقيا
والولايات المتحده الك اليسار في صحيفه ه
جدعون ليفي يؤكد ماهيه الفصل العنصري ضد
الفلسطينيين ويحذر قومه الاسرائيليين من
ان نهايتنا لن تكون جيده اذا استمرينا في
هذا
الاحتلال bl
is
senty about are us in times of war
obviously and they are not even curious
to know what is happening half an hour
away from our homes and half an hour
away from our homes even before this
horrible war there is inhuman reality
which must come one and
asue blindness
يقولون ان من جاع سيكون اكثر فهما لمعنى
الجوع ومن احتلت ارضه واستعبد شعبه هو
الاكثر وعيا لقيمه الحريه لذلك كانت جنوب
افريقيا سباقه في الدفاع عن
الفلسطينيين الاردنيون ككل العرب يشكرون
جنوب افريقيا وقد عبروا عن ذلك لسره كيب
تاون في عمان
[موسيقى]
الكاتب العبري افي ليبكين لا يساوره شك
بان اسرائيل ستحتل في النهايه مكه
والمدينه وجبل سيناء ولبنان بل ويقول
سنعمل على تطهير هذه
الاماكن علما ان مصنع حديده في غزه انتج
اسلحه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه لم تستطع
ترسانه اسرائيل اقصاها حتى
[موسيقى]
الان med
us
المانيا لم تكتفي بتاييد اسرائيل عن بعد
بل انضمت للدفاع عنها طرفا ثالثا في محكمه
العدل الدوليه ليس هذا فحسب بل اصبح
الاعتراف بشرعيه وجود اسرائيل شرطا للحصول
على الجنسيه الالمانيه في ولايه ساكسونا
ثم ياتيك مغترب او متاف او مهجر عربي في
المانيا ليفتي
للفلسطينيين ماذا يفعلون وكيف يقاومون اذا
كنت في ولايه ساكسونيا انهلت واردت الحصول
على الجنسيه الالمانيه فعليك الاعتراف بحق
اسرائيل في الوجود القانون الجديد دخل لتو
حيز التنفيذ وبموجبه اصبح لزاما على طالب
الجنسيه الالمانيه ملء استماره يدعم فيها
حق اسرائيل في الوجود وينى بنفسه عن اي
سلوك يصنف ضمن خانه معاداه الساميه
محامي الدفاع عن اسرائيل في لاهاي مالكم
شو يستبد التوتر باصابعه فيضيع اوراق
ملفاته مرتين اثناء كلمته فكان اسهل شيء
عليه ان يتهم مجهولا بخلط
اوراقه
اوكي بينما كان محامو الدفاع عن اسرائيل
يحاولون الطلب من العالم ان يعمي عيونه عن
مشاهد الهولوكوست الحيه بغزه كان عضو
الكنيسه نسيم فطوري يعبر عن انزعاجه لعدم
انتهاء جيش الاحتلال حتى الان من احراق
غزه بمن فيها لتتفوق داف دوله اسرائيل من
الفرات للن
ها منم
يه منصف على محرقه غزه تظاهر امام مقر
المحكمه في لاهاي ووصف سوق اسرائيل بتهمه
ارتكابها اباده جماعيه للمره الاولى في
التاريخ وصفه باليوم
[موسيقى]
التاريخي
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي الاسبق موشي يعلون
يكشف المستور في تل ابيب الان حكومه تؤمن
بان عليها واجب هو نشر الحروب والفوضى
واستدعاء قوم ياجوج وماجوج الى الحرب
الكبرى
ز
صح
فرن
je les nazir le projet paster les juif
cit de les faire partir volon ais le
bien c'est incroyable qu' don raison qui
accus actuellement isra de un gci gaza
parce que de forc une population c'est
un gci etal qui est par les plus vir
d'l entre isra et les nazis c'est une
folie mme que quelqu'un pu penser c'est
ilut les par
que
je شعبيه ضخمه في صنعاء مؤيده لجماعه
انصار الله المؤيده لحركه حماس بعد
الضربات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه على مواقعها في اليمن صنعاء
تظاهر مئات الالاف من المناصرين للحوثيين
مظاهره للتاكيد على تاييد الحوثيين
وللتنديد بالضربات الامريكيه والبريطانيه
على اهداف للحوثيين المؤيدين لحركه حماس
المتحدث باسم جماعه انصار الله الحوثي ندد
بالضربات اقدم العدو الامريكي البريطاني
على شن عدوان غاشم على الجمهوريه اليمنيه
ب 73 غاره ولن يمر دون عجاب من منع
المساعدات الانسانيه عن غزه اسرائيل تفتري
على الحكومه المصريه ويقول محاميها في
محكمه العدل الدوليه مالكوم شو ان اسرائيل
لم تمنع دخول المساعدات لغزه وان مصر
مسؤوله بالكامل عن معبر رفح علما ان وزير
الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري قال في منتصف
اكتوبر الماضي لا تملك مصر قرار ادخال
المساعدات الانسانيه
الى غزه نفت مصر بصوره قاطعه مزاعم
واكاذيب فريق الدفاع الاسرائيلي امام
محكمه العدل الدوليه بان مصر هي المسؤوله
عن منع دخول المساعدات الانسانيه والاغاثه
الى قطاع غزه من الجانب المصري لمعبر رفح
واوضح رئيس الهيئه العامه للاستعلامات
دياء رشوان ان تهافت ان تها ان تهق وكذب
الادعاءات الاسرائيليه يتضح في عدد من
النقاط من بينها تاكيد كل المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين وفي مقدمتهم رئيس الوزراء في
تصريحات علنيه بانهم لن يسمحوا بدخول
المساعدات لقطاع غزه في ظل العدوان الذي
تشنه اسرائيل على القطاع بكل الاحوال توقع
محللون ان تحشر الحكومه المصريه اسرائيل
وتفتح معبر رفح امام قوافل المساعدات
الانسانيه لاختبارها وتعريتها عمليا امام
العالم في حال اقدامها على منع ادخال
مساعدات بالقوه خصوصا مع تعاظم الغضب
المصري من حديث اسرائيل عن نيتها السيطره
على محور فيلادلفيا بغزه الحدو مع مصر
اسرائيل تسعى للاستيلاء على اخر حدود لغزه
لا تسيطر عليها تحت هذا العنوان كتبت
صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال تقريرا كشفت فيه
عن ابلاغ مسؤولين اسرائيليين القاهره انهم
يخططون لتنفيذ عمليه عسكريه للسيطره على
حدود قطاع غزه مع مصر في اشاره الى محور
فيلادلفيا بحسب الصحيفه فان القاهره رفضت
مقترحا اسرائيليا يتضمن نشر افراد امن
اسرائيليين على الجانب المصري من الحدود
لتنفيذ دوريات مشتركه مع مصر قائله ان ذلك
سينته السياده المصريه في هذه الاثناء
طفله فلسطينيه عند السياج الحدودي بين مصر
وغزه تترجى جنديا مصريا ليعطيها ما تاكله
عمي بدي بسكوت جوعانه
تقول
اخيرا قنصل مصر السابق في تل ابيب السفير
رفعه الانصاري يتباهى بامته علاقات نسائيه
محرمه مع اسرائيليات اثناء ادائه مهمته
الدبلوماسيه ويعلن ان الاسرائيليين صوروا
ممارساته خلسه لكنه لا يابه الا لمدى
اعجابهم بادائه ويقول لقد رفعت راس رجال
مصر عاليا كلام سوقي قد يسوقه الى المحاكم
المصريه بتهمه اساءه تمثيل بلاده وتعريض
هيبتها للشبهات
وتسفيه العمل الدبلوماسي يعلق حقوقي مصري
انا كنت دائما العلاقات النسائيه اسعى ما
انها تكون ذات فائده سياسيه ان لم تكن
فائده معلومات امنيه ومخبر يعني ربما ا
كنت تسقط يعني صيدا ثمينا لل المساد او
لغيره من خلال تصويرك او من خلال ابتزاز ك
ويتم تجنيدك المساله دي الم تكن
تقلق الا تعتقد ان انا اتز قش عليا عشرات
امم كنت بتفرز ازاي بقى كنت تقدر تفرز
ازاي لا ده الفرز ده موهبه شخصيه يعني
وخبره
ف وبعدين هو مين قال لك ان هم ما سجلوا
ليش
لا سجلو
لي انما كل ما هو كان
مسجل
كان داخل غرفه نوم لم يكن فيه كلمه واحده
مني مع اي حد على اي موضوع
شغل فحتى ساعتها اما قيل لي قيل ليه قالوا
لي هم سجلك قلتلهم مافيش ولا كلمه شغل
قالولي لا الحقيقه لا قلتلهم طيب قالوا بس
حبينا نقول لك ان انت تسجل طب ايه رايك في
الاداء المصري كان شكل قاللي لا الحمد لله
رفعت راس مصر عاليا لكل الرجال الحمد لله
ودي في حد ذاتها رساله
يعني ختاما يى ان الناصر صلاح الدين
الايوبي وقبل تحريره بيت المقدس كان يقول
والله اني لاستحي من الله ان اضحك والمسجد
الاقصى مازال محتلا من
الصليبيين الحياء نعمه وقد صنفه رسول الله
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم بانه شعبه من شعب
الايمان وقال النبي الكريم استحيوا من
الله حق الحياء وقال ايضا عليه الصلاه
والسلام ان مما ادرك الناس من كلام النبوه
الاولى اذا لم تستحي فاصنع ما شئت في
الخلاصه كثر الصانعون لما يشاؤون بغير
حساب
وقل الحياء بين
الاحياء الى اللقاء حج كيف
حالك ايش بتعمل ه يا
حج وصلي من ويند
تتوضح من
البحر ط مش برد عليك يا حج مش برد
[موسيقى]
عليك
ا
[موسيقى]
ا فخور فخور باسلام
فمنه ارتويت انا
الظامي هداني الهي بعيد
العباد لدين عظيم هو
السامي بدين عظيم هو
السامي فخور
فخور
[موسيقى]
ان